set phasers to kill mother so the rumor
had been bouncing around for a little
while that Quentin Tarantino of all
people was in talks to work on the next
Star Trek film and all somebody didn't
pay too much attention to because they
you know it was an early report and and
I didn't think much of it but it does
actually at this point appear to be
moving forward now it's it's still not a
guarantee that the thing actually gets
made you know there has to be finished
script that paramount actually green
lights but right now they've approved
development with Quentin Tarantino
working on the story they brought in
scriptwriter the guy who wrote the
revenant to work on it as well so that
Tarantino at the moment can doesn't have
to split time with his working on the
the Manson movie that he's doing at JJ
Abrams is gonna produce so this thing's
moving forward and in finding that out
there was a detail that if this was
reported earlier I missed it and it's
the fact that it could be rated R which
I mean it's Quentin Tarantino so like
duh but it is an r-rated Star Trek
really and that's that's kind of where
my head's at now I know itself the idea
of Quentin Tarantino wanting to do Star
Trek's seems weird but it's actually not
if you know a little bit about the
history of the stuff that he's talked
about but he's never done cuz actually
she's been talking about wanting to mess
around in franchises for a long long
time like I remember gavel back when I
lived in Boston that he was talking
about how he wanted to get his hands on
something like Friday the 13th yeah he
was in talks not to direct but to we're
gonna script for a James Bond at one
point so you know that's this is
necessarily completely unheard of that
he shows interest not nothing's ever
gotten this far though so it is it is
still a little weird and on the one hand
like Tarantino has always been able to
do his own stories his own characters
his own concepts he's never had to play
in someone else's playground before but
then again and on the other hand like
his entire filmography is all about
remix engaño tropes and staples and you
know established things from genres that
he loves so you know it's not totally
out of his wheelhouse but it's that our
rating idea that has me that has me very
nervous now a couple benefit of the
doubt things first off the agreement as
I understand it is it was conditional
from him if he was gonna work on this
that Paramount had to allow him to do an
r-rated film that does not necessarily
mean he will but it means that if that's
what he decides to do they have to say
if they approve the script that can't
code this is great but you have to tone
it on the pg-13 if they take it they
take it as is even if it's our but it
doesn't necessarily mean it has to be
but it doesn't mean he has the option
and knowing Tarantino's track record
it's hard to imagine him churning out a
script that wouldn't be a de dar but but
I mean being fair it's not a guarantee
that it would be so that's the first
benefit about the other thing is the
concerns that I'm gonna talk about I
would be willing to dismiss all of them
if we find out that he is writing
completely original characters but and
telling a story with characters we
haven't seen before or like characters
we know are only cameo Eng and it's just
set in the Star Trek universe or
honestly even if he's dealing with some
of the you know ethically murky or stuff
like a little bit like Deus nine sort of
dealt with I could probably roll with
that but if he's tackling Kirk and Spock
or the next generation cast and oral
characters I don't want those to be
r-rated and I think kind of
at a fundamental level I think that
that's and that's just a bad idea and I
don't I don't think it's just a matter
of my taste I mean the those those two
works the original series and TNG they
were the ones that had Gene
Roddenberry's hands directly on them and
he very deliberately created something
that was optimistic and forward-thinking
and hopeful and aspirational Quentin
Tarantino doesn't really do any of those
things and also those are things that
don't lend themselves to our ratings
anyways and again that's not me saying
Star Trek as a universal franchise can
never go there but the characters that
Roddenberry created and and the specific
vision that he had it is supposed to be
this wonderful future that we are
building towards and we should be
looking forward to and I don't want to
see those characters sullied and that's
not me trying to be like they're perfect
how dare you change them and and I'm not
even gonna make the argument that it
that there's no good stories to be done
out of it or that Tarantino or any
artist wouldn't have you know some kind
of artistic
right to do whatever they wanted but I
just I I don't have it in me anymore
like if there was whatever part of me
that wanted to see you know the the Boy
Scouts taken down a peg I've grown out
of that or maybe I've grown out of it or
maybe I've just I've been spending too
much time in the last year or two just
seeing all the stuff going on both in
entertainment in the things I consume
and in the real world and it's just I'm
tired of it I have watched Superman
become a dour figure who doesn't seem to
want to actually help people I have
watched a spoiler alert for the last
Jedi Luke Skywalker become a sullen
bitter person who has completely
disengaged from the rest of society and
I've watched actors and directors and
creators that I loved and whose works I
loved turn out to be some degree of
monstrous in their personal life I'm
really tired and burnt out of seeing the
ugliness and the dark underbelly of my
heroes I I lost my taste for it if I
ever had it so Quentin I don't know what
you're planning and I'm sure whatever it
is even if it is the thing about I'm
dreading I'm sure it's better than
anything that I could ever write I I I'm
not trying to argue that but I like
Quentin Tarantino's movies but there is
a through line of a certain degree of
cynicism of nihilism almost that runs
through his films that I'm hesitant to
see applied to Star Trek at all and I
really really really don't want to see
applied to Kirk or Spock or bones or
Picard or Riker or data and just Quentin
just let them let them be please and I I
know Patrick Stewart has said you know
how great it would be if he could work
with Quentin Tarantino I would love to
see him at a Quentin Tarantino movie but
I don't want to see a Tarantino Picard I
rolled with watching Charles Xavier safe
you know and was fine with it but it's
an
and and Star Trek isn't even like one of
my major fandoms I mean I like Star Trek
I've always liked Star Trek but like
there isn't even any series of Star Trek
that I've seen every single episode of
next generation is probably my favorite
I haven't seen every episode of next
generation I've seen all the movies but
that's also because it takes less time
to watch all the movies and it does any
any of the series front to back and I'm
just a little bit more of a movie guy
anyway but I guess the tone of this
manin it to be so dour and almost kind
of pleading but I just I really want us
as consumers and definitely the people
producing our entertainment to if not
completely get over at least hit the
pause button on deconstructions and dark
reimagining and laying the Heroes low I
don't know how much more strength I have
for it especially for characters that I
I feel don't have any business being
handled that way so I think that's about
it this for you again considering that
Star Trek is not something that I mean
again I like it I do care about it but
I'm not in deeply passionate about it
but something about this news just hit
me in an existential way and I don't
like the way it feels and hopefully I'm
wrong or barring that if I'm wrong I
hope that woody if he does this if it
happens if it goes through I hope it's
amazing and wonderful and I completely
crow that's what I hope I just I can't
run on hope anymore I I have to be
upfront about my concerns in my fear
about things and yeah this this this one
raises some fears that feel more deeply
rooted and they do sometimes so those
are my thoughts on the possibility of
Quentin Tarantino directing a Star Trek
film and the idea that it could be
r-rated Oh what are your thoughts on
this whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
go ahead and like subscribe all that
stuff Twitter podcast links down below
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]